hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the 2010 world blitz
championship it's played between
Demetria Dracon and the Segway Kerrigan
now I wasn't planning on doing any more
videos today but I did prepare a poll
for you to vote for my next big series
so I decided to do this short video I
just invite you to vote the link to the
poll for you to vote will be in the
description below it will be the first
thing you will see as soon as I posted
it some people have already voted there
you can see that already
over a thousand votes have been placed
and so far as it seems it will be a race
between Carson and Couric in rematch and
the capablanca saga but also I don't
know due to the time difference maybe
Todd vs. botanique will also get their
fair share of votes I don't know perhaps
in the morning I will and and maybe even
understand its vs. to court but the
least votes came for carp of saga and I
really thought as we just finished above
the future saga you would be very
interested to see how the whole story
continues which anatoly karpov but you
know I'll leave it up for a couple of
days and we'll see where you guys stand
on and what did the next big series
should be now regarding this game it's
really impressive as it is a game
between two grandmasters like we said
it's the world blitz championship and
before I show this game is if it's a
really short game I would just like to
show you two other extremely short games
not counting the one the one who even
played in the I believe it's 2016
Gibraltar trader Weis festival where she
lost on purpose in five moves so without
counting that there is a very nice game
I always like to show people where white
goes d4 Knight of 6 and then white plays
this silly Knights 2d to move and black
immediately replies with e5 pawn
captures Knight g4 and after White's
tries to kick away the night thinking
that okay black just wants to grab his
pawn back our black plays Knight to e3
and the white can resign because next
move white will either lose the Queen or
if the knight is captured
checkmate follows after Queen to h4
check g3 and Queen captures on g3 with
checkmate now although this is a very
nice
basically what can resign in four moves
I don't think it was ever played between
grandmasters and I don't think it's it's
possible to really find out who was the
first to have played this game but the
strongest players I have found to finish
their games like this is between two
feet in masters but of course you could
also go back to a hundred years ago to
1910 to a game between rich of the
Vettii and solitaire talk over you all
know that a very nice game if for c6 d 4
D 5 we already actually showed this game
on my channel but I showed it as a
Simpsons episode as this game was
featured in one of episodes of The
Simpsons so basically a nice caro-kann
game where after Queen captures here why
decided the castle and here retty offers
his knight on e4 now of course you
cannot capture with the Queen because
rookie won't travel to the Queen but Tok
Tok over actually thought that Knight
captures on e4 was possible and here
retty just played Queen d8 check and it
was in this position that Sally thought
ocular resigned at the game what would
follow here is after the Queen is
captured the Bishop g5 check and now
whatever the black King place either
this then rook to the 8 will be
checkmate or if the King goes here then
Bishop to d8 will be checkmate as the
bishop is covering b6 and the rook is
controlling the entire D file and while
those games are very nice first one
isn't really between grandmasters and
the second one was playing more than 100
years ago where you could actually
expect anything to happen in the chess
game but this is 2010 pretty much a
modern chess so I'm very happy to show
you this game unbreaking opens the game
with c4 so the English opening we have
85 Knight to c3 Knight to c6 so we have
the reverse Sicilian on the board where
white basically has an extra tempo
Knight to f3 we have g6 and now d4 we
have pawn captures on d4 Knight to d5
here you could capture and the foreign
the game would simply continue for
example Bishop g7 Knight captures pawn
captures and after E for basically the
game would continue as as a struggle who
would be able to control the d5 square
but he runned raking after
after Sundy for already decides to mix
it up to plays Knight to d5 Bishop to g7
a very nice replied by kurakin and here
Bishop to g5 already attacking the Queen
and here we have an excellent position
where there are a lot of good moves for
black here black is actually doing very
well here black can play Knight C to e
7th to block this check black can play
Knight to f6 black can actually even
play f6 it is possible in this position
but the move Parkin played is not
possible here Cara can play Knight G to
e7 and here comes the problem I'm sure
you can all see it
the problem is Knight captures on d4 and
it seems like an odd decision the knight
is attacked twice here why would under I
can simply give up a night well the
problem is if you capture with the night
then this Knight is no longer guarding
this night and then Bishop captures is a
problem you're gonna lose the Queen here
and why is it gonna win the game
but what's the problem with Bishop
captures on d4 seemingly nothing and
this is exactly what Cara can played he
played special captures only for as this
is blitz you know the other guy might
miss something as well but now again
surely you will see what whom what is to
come here here Andre can played Queen
captures on d4 and now Kraken is in huge
problems this has only moved 8 and
already there there are a lot of
problems for for him to solve if you
actually accept the Queen sacrifice then
the knight captures Knight to f6 check
King to f8 and Bishop to h6 this ends in
checkmate
on the other hand after Queen captures
on d4 if you try to block it with f6
not really not really anything to look
forward to do Knight captures on f6
check and after King if 7 queen is
coming to a4 and now all sorts of nasty
discoveries are being threatened you
can't really unpin here the knife
controls all these squares if you go
here then Bishop to h6 is a terrible
threat so black would be lost here very
very quickly and lastly but not leastly
of course after Knight captures on d5
thinking ok you capture my queen or then
capture your queen
it's actually amazing one Queen captures
on h8 as the bishop is controlling d7
square so already I move it
of fireworks so Carrick and decided to
castle here but it doesn't help him all
that much here and Reagan is actually
threatening a force checkmate in five so
feel free to pause the video here and
beat Sergei Cara Kim you know as in any
way you can so I'll give you a couple of
seconds as usual for those of you who
are able to do it congratulations you
have just beaten a grandmaster in under
ten moves and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show here on draygon
played nice to f6 check and here you can
either play King g7 or King to h8 but
both moves are going under the Queen's
mask so of course you don't want to play
King g7 then a double check is possible
after something like Knights to e8 or h5
check it's a double check the bishop is
controlling these squares you have to go
back and then it's making one so kurakin
decided to go King to h8 and now Knight
to 8 wouldn't really do all that much as
it's not a double check
you heard there's a nice capture screen
and you know black would just laugh at
you so after this Knight to f6 check
King to h8 was played and now comes
Knight to g4 check now it's a discover
check from the Queen and yes the Queen
is offered you don't really have a lot
of options here but it was in this
position that Sevilla Cara can decided
to resign the game why did he resign
well pretty much everything you do not
pretty much everything you do does lose
you the game the most straightforward
Knight captures on d4 would lose the
bishop to have six check King moves and
the knight to h6 checkmate on the other
hand after Knight to g4 check you don't
really have all that many options if you
simply block it's the same checkmate
and of course mm you could block would
have six and then of course you cannot
end the game in great style with Queen
captures on f6 unfortunately here knight
Knight to h6 will not be checkmate as
the rook is no longer on f8 so you can
play King to f8
but after f6 you can play Bishop
captures and now it will again be
checkmate captures captures and after
King g8 and night to h6 this will be
checkmate
so after this Knight to g4 check
hurricane resigned the game so this is
ten moves I don't know if there are any
shorter games between grandmasters I'm
sure there are but as this is you know
Sergey Karjakin and Dimitri I'm taking
two really big names I thought you'd
really enjoy this one about there I'm
basically just inviting you to vote on
the next series there you have it you
know be sure to vote I mean it don't
stress about it too much I mean every
vote does count but we are gonna cover
all the games all the events and all the
cool stories that have happened in the
chess world so you might not get your
series right right away but it will come
at some point so you know don't don't
worry about it too much if your series
isn't the next one to be chosen assume
that's basically that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Doug was Broward CCGs chess club a
Robert Sullivan at the Metra PCOS and
Sylvan Heba for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos er thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content thank you all and I'll see you
soon